Our last step is to make sure
that our progressive web app
can become a first class citizen, and
isn't relegated only to the browser, but
can exist outside of there.
When a native app is installed, it's
automatically added to the users home
screen place it where the user will see
it every time they look at their device.
With the add to home screen feature,
users can choose to add your app to
their home screen just as an installed
native app gets from the store but
with a lot less friction.
Then, adding a web app manifest,
your web app can choose the name and
icons used that will
appear on the home screen.
Be launched in full screen
mode with no URL bar,
control the screen orientation for
optimal viewing,
define a splash screen launch
experience and theme color and
even track wether you'll launch from
the home screen or the URL bar.
The web app manifest is
supported by Chrome, Opera, and
Firefox, plus Microsoft
is investigating it.
Safari on iOS is a little bit different,
but we will cover that too.
And of course you'll be putting
all of this knowledge to use
on your weather app, and
then deploying it to the Web.
Let's jump in.